[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département et ce mercredi 8 février
parole à paul martinez le président de
l'udps et 78 la section départementale a
tenu récemment une conférence de presse
en commun avec le modem
l'occasion pour le centre de faire le
point sur les échéances locales et
nationales qui vont marquer l'agenda des
prochains mois paroles aussi dans cette
émission a tiré du gué le directeur du
parc de thoiry tu sera avec nous en
plateau pour nous présenter les
nouveautés qui concernent le parquet le
zoo de thoiry entre naissances et
découverte du château mais politique
donc pour débuter cette émission et le
centre qui se rassemblent en tout cas au
niveau local modem et u10 ont tenu il ya
quelques jours une conférence de presse
commune pour célébrer 2010 est un temps
des changes pour évoquer les enjeux
locaux mais aussi pour évoquer les
prochaines élections après bruno myle
yens président du modem 78 la semaine
passée je vous propose d'écouter
maintenant paul martinez président de
l'udps et des yvelines au micro de
wilfrid richy modem udi qui organise
donc leurs voeux conjointement pour ce
début d'année 2010 est avec le
responsable de l'ue dès à présent dans
le département des yvelines on a vu tout
à l'heure bruno myle yens pour le modem
expliquez-nous un petit peu aussi vos
intention d'organiser aujourd'hui
conjointement ces petites rentrer
ensemble pour 2010 16 il s'agit de
positionner un peu la famille centriste
sur le département localement pour pour
faire en sorte
le dialogue continue parce que bon
quelles que soient les les échéances
électorales nationales les centristes
modem u10 sont toujours ont toujours
dialoguer sont toujours rencontré avec
des stratégies parfois différentes
parfois payantes aussi je pense aux
européennes en 2014
la liste modem udi avait avait fait 15 %
quand même dans le département donc ça
veut dire que il ya quand même à votre
centriste quelque part localement et
l'idée de marquer le coup à l'échelle du
département c'est d'envoyer aussi un
message c'est à dire que au niveau
national les stratégies sont peut-être
pas les mêmes mais de dire aux habitants
que au niveau local on n'a vraiment pas
le plus souvent une feuille de papier à
cigarette d'épaisseur entre nos
convictions et le point de vue qu'on a
sur les différents projets locaux
départementaux régionaux et communaux
bien sûr vous pouvez affirmer ce
positionnement centriste ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une distance qui
s'opère aussi avec les républicains non
ya pas une distance avec les
républicains pour ce qui est de lui dis
parce que modem est dans une logique
différente pour ce qui est du pays
il ya toujours des discussions qui
avance apparemment qui devrait avancer
de façon plus incertaine au niveau des
négociations mais la politique c'est
laid
et les négociations d'appareil mais
c'est aussi le contenu des projets et de
ce point de vue là effectivement il
faudra nous peser dans cette élection
présidentielle si on doit soutenir le
candidat fillon il faudra peser sur les
thématiques qui sont propres à notre
famille c'est à dire l'environnement
enfin je vous rappelle que jean louis
borloo qui le créateur de lui dit et
quand même
aussi le père du grenelle de
l'environnement chantal jouanno qui est
chez nous aussi enfin il ya des figures
illustres qui travaillent sur ces
questions là l'europe bien sûr on
n'entend pas beaucoup parler d'europe et
s'il ya une famille politique qui est
particulièrement soucieuse du bien-être
du projet un requin c'est nous et il va
mal le projet européen donc plutôt que
de tirer sur l'ambulance il faudrait
peut-être penser à refonder un peu
l'europe et on nous en parle pas trop
denses dans ces présidentielles ça nous
inquiète et le candidat fillon resté
plutôt plutôt absents sur ces questions
là donc il faudra effectivement apporté
ces questions là et bien sûr la
dimension humaniste et sociale qui nous
anime depuis depuis l'histoire du centre
des radicaux jusque jusqu'aux centristes
jusqu'au père fondateur de l'europe que
son show man monnaie jusqu'à notre
époque jean louis borloo même françois
bayrou j'allais dire jeu christophe
lagarde et tous ceux qui font centre
aujourd'hui il la faire aujourd'hui
françois fillon pénélope fillon ça peut
vous éloignez également des républicains
ça d'auditionner sur un autre candidat
saad emmanuel macron par exemple alors
oui on parle beaucoup de guides oui
voilà on parle beaucoup de lui je sais
que c'est l'homme qui est
particulièrement ciblée par les médias
emmanuel macron séduit séduit beaucoup y
compris dans de grands faut pas non plus
faire de langue de bois pour autant
voilà une méthode à l'évidence qui est
intéressante mais il ya un contenu que
qui est encore imprécis à l'évidence
donc on va voir ce qu'ils proposent à
passionnant où nous l'a dit dit on a
décidé effectivement de soutenir le
candidat fillon c'est aussi pour faire
en sorte de ne peser dans les changes et
de faire en sorte que nos thématiques
centristes puissent être portées par le
candidat fillon je pense est évident
donc c'est ce qu'on souhaite de toute
façon nouvelle udi pour autant
vous me parliez de petits ailleurs
médiatique
je laisserai la justice régler toutes
ces affaires là pour l'instant il ya une
audience aujourd'hui en urgence on verra
ce que ça donne
je préfère pas supputer parce que si
il s'avère finalement que ce n'est pas
du tout le résultat escompté
parce que beaucoup devraient eux
à terme j'allais dire battre leur coulpe
donc en l'occurrence on attend de voir
s'il ya une issue positive à tout ça on
tentera de tourner la page le plus
positivement possible ça laissera quand
même des séquelles malgré tout parce que
ya quand même eu une séquence médiatique
très très forte sur cette question là je
pense que pour l'instant la réaction et
la bonne c'est à dire de d'accélérer la
procédure judiciaire pour que tout soit
très clair d'emblée on verra ce que ça
donne effectivement à terme
quant à emmanuel macron voilà pour
l'instant c'est un phénomène médiatico
politique
est-ce qu'il transformera l'essai on
verra le contenu est pas encore très
précis comme tous les films on va voir
il est vrai que bon parmi nos rangs et
du délit comme modem il séduit une toute
dernière question pour 2017
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter à l'idée
d'être présente tant nationalement ce
qui est compliqué parce que on a fait
des choix d'alliance qui nous laisse pas
beaucoup de place de visibilité mais on
est toujours là
en espérant qu'on ait des élus qui
portent vraiment notre différence au
sein d'une éventuelle future majorité
avec les républicains eux
et puis d'être d'être aussi très
présents localement me semble-t-il parce
que c'est la réalité elle est locale en
fait des habitants sont de plus en plus
axé vers le local
le national leur paraître un ballet
médiatique assez lointain et et par
moments un peu un peu hors sol en
quelque sorte en l'occurrence ils ont
confiance dans leurs élus locaux ils ont
confiance dans leur mère le plus souvent
vous savez c'est le maire qui incarne le
plus de confiance pour pour les
habitants donc on va essayer de
recentrer ses discussions c'est ça aussi
la thématique un peu de cet échange avec
le modem c'est de se retrouver sur des
problématiques locales et d'anticiper
les échéances de 2020 qui seront
importantes notamment pour les
municipales et les élections
intercommunale vous le savez comme moi
les intercommunalités sont sont très
forte actuellement de retour en plateau
à présent avec thierry du vié directeur
du parc de thoiry bonsoir bonsoir le
parc de thoiry qui a rouvert ses portes
c'était samedi la semaine passée samedi
4 février précisément déjà dites nous
comment se sont passées ces premiers
jours est ce que les gens étaient au
rendez vous pour ces premiers jours
c'est ce début de saison 2017 alors
c'était quand même un petit peu venteux
et pluvieux veulent le week-end était
quand même pas très très beau donc ça
mais sans remettre en route aussi
progressivement voilà on s'est remis en
route doucement mais aujourd'hui
j'arrive tout juste sait on a fait une
très belle journée avec plein de plein
de monde
et pourtant le temps était correcte mais
sans plus pour un mois de février voilà
mais c'est bien alors avant de parler
des nouveautés 2010 est déjà est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer vous étiez
firmi depuis la mi novembre
on les gens qui ne savent pas ça sert à
quoi d'être fermée tout l'hiver pourquoi
vous êtes aussi fermé tous les verts
vous partez en vacances avec avec les
animaux non non non non mais on profite
du fait qu'il ya moins de
visite pour refaire un certain nombre
d'enclos pour réaménager pour permettre
à des nouveaux animaux de pouvoir venir
donc c'est une période où nous avons
besoin ou effectivement c'est un petit
peu boueux on fait des travaux
voilà donc pour améliorer ça fait du
bien aussi aux animaux peut-être de se
retrouvé un peu plus isolé que
d'habitude ça joue là dessus aussi où
ses parents que c'est mou lent au nom
même quelques fois on se dit tiens
depuis voir personne si ça se trouve ça
les stresse pas ce que parce que
finalement ils sont habitués non je
crois il
non je ne crois pas que ça les salles et
repose parlez nous des nouveautés pour
cette saison 2017 et forcément des
nouveaux animaux qu'on pourra voir toute
cette saison alors déjà on a eu des
plein de bébés
donc on a mis aussi cette période à
profit pour pour que nos animaux de
naissance à des on en voilà quelques-uns
à l'écran voilà donc on a eu donc des
bébés yens maintenant qu'ils sont
qui ont déjà quatre mois mais qui
sortent on a eu des pb des bébés
panthères qui sont absolument superbes
des panthères de noir de chine des
panthères de shin tai chi que j'ai eus
voilà voilà voilà donc ça c'est quand
même cédé très beau on a des loutres ont
cédé des bébés loutres d'asie qui sont
aussi très mignonne on a des petits
autruchons enfin bon il ya quand même
plein plein de naissance donc ça c'est
superbe
et puis alors ya des nouveaux animaux
qui sont arrivés près on a une femelle
louve arctique donc un loup blanc ce
qu'on avait déjà un mal donc là la
femelle est arrivé hier donc le mal
était quand même tous contents
aujourd'hui dans son dans sa réserve de
pouvoir aller trouver une femelle donc
ça c'est superbe
et puis plein de nouveautés qui vont
arriver c'est important de se renouveler
chaque année d'avoir de nouveaux animaux
pour aussi attirer un nouveau public
en tout cas faire revenir les gens de se
dire que d'une année sur l'autre des
choses ont changé oui mais c'est très
sain pour se réinventer
c'est très important donc on est tout le
temps dans un constant souci
d'amélioration d'agrandissement d'abel
et d'embellissement des enclos de
nouvelles espèces qui viennent tout ça
pour le bonheur de nos de nos visiteurs
un mot aussi sur une autre nouveauté qui
ne concerne pas les animaux mais le pass
annuel de 38 euros pour les adultes à 32
euros pour les enfants
oui impasse avec lequel on pourra venir
quand on veut toute l'année alors
quasiment parce que c'est juste sont
exclus juste les sept jours fériés
d'accord en dehors de ces sept jours
fériés effectivement pour 38 euros
les visiteurs peuvent venir quand il
veut quand ils veulent et ça c'est
vraiment un petit peu une grande
nouveauté
parce que on pense que c'est une belle
occasion pour emmener ses enfants rient
emmené à toutes les saisons de l'année
et pouvoir le parc doit revoir
d'éventuellement les bébés dont on parle
est il exactement
racontez-nous vous qui êtes le directeur
du parc de thoiry
quels sont les ingrédients pour une
bonne saison et est ce que la météo
c'est primordial quels sont les autres
éléments qui sont qui joue qui sont
prépondérants pour avoir une bonne
saison
la météo la météo si l'élève la météo
oui c'est l'élément principal
le deuxième élément c'est aussi les
vacances les ponts a notamment au mois
de mai l'année dernière série d'annoncés
bâtir une bonne année alors cette année
c'est une bonne année
voilà c'est pour ça que nous on a en
plus mis notre passeport à 38 euros
notamment pour les habitants des
yvelines particulièrement destiné pour
eux justement sur ce qu'il ya plein de
pont il ya plein de choses à faire donc
donc la météo une météo ensoleillée des
ponts et puis des bébés animaux qui sont
puisque c'est quand même très souvent un
motif de désirs des réseaux wi bien sûr
donc c'est pour ça que cette année on
est très excités et que tous les bébés
qu'on a eus content de les présenter au
public un mot pour terminer sur un
événement qui arrive très bientôt la
saint valentin le parc de thoiry ou
plutôt le château propose aux amoureux
un dîner exceptionnel est ce qu très
rapidement à 30 secondes vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus sur ce c'est un
dîner qu'on fait dans ce superbe château
de thoiry donc pour les origines lors de
la saint valentin
voilà donc on peut manger donc dans la
salle à manger dans ce magnifique
château une demeure familiale et qui
ouvre exceptionnellement ses portes aux
amoureux de le du jour de la saint
valentin
voilà et pour plus d'information pour
les éventuels téléspectateurs intéressés
ils peuvent se rendre sur www.paris.fr
merci
tiré du guide est revenue en plateau et
donc vallée saison à vous merci
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir prochain rendez vous demain
jeudi 9 janvier excellente soirée sur tv
fil 78
[Musique]